Und weil ich dich so sehr mag
und gern in deine Richtung lenk
und weil du mir so viel bedeutest
bist du ein Geschenk
Du bist ein Geschenk
20 Jahre Sportfreunde Stiller:
Auf dem neuen Album „Sturm und Stille“
verbreiten sie wieder gute Laune.
Doch angesichts von Krieg und Terror
gibt es auch nachdenkliche Töne.
Wir haben ’ne super Zeit,
wir waren total zufrieden und happy
da in unserem Musikmachen
und in unserem Musikrausch.
Und auf der anderen Seite waren
wir echt sehr traurig darüber,
was da so draußen in der Welt passiert,
und haben eben gespürt diese
Gleichzeitigkeit extremer …
extrem unterschiedlicher Gefühle.
Raus, raus in den Rausch
Viel Spaß beim Schweben
Inzwischen sieben Studioalben,
drei Echos, sieben Mal Platin:
Mit Jubel-Hymnen und schnörkellosen
Texten haben sich die Indie-Rocker
in zwei Jahrzehnten eine
riesige Fan-Gemeinde erspielt.
Alles, was wir haben, ist irgendwie
auf Jubel gebaut.
Das ist alles so wahnsinnig
positiv entstanden durch …
durch das, dass man Musik macht
einfach und dass die Menschen einen halt
mit Freude irgendwie durch die
Welt durch tragen.
Ich wollte dir nur mal eben sagen
dass du das Größte für mich bist
2002 der erste Top-Ten-Hit: ein Liebeslied.
Doch ihre größte Liebe gilt dem Fußball.
Die Hobby-Kicker nehmen 2004
mit Roque Santa Cruz,
dem damaligen Star des
FC Bayern München, einen Song auf.
Wie ich zocke
ich sag’s nur meinem Fanblock
Ich Roque
Rocken ist ja quasi ein Lebensgefühl,
würde ich sagen.
1 und 2 und 3 und 54, 74, 90, 2006
ja so stimmen wir alle ein
2006 rocken sie die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft.
Ihr Song wird zur inoffiziellen
Hymne der WM im eigenen Land
– und liefert den Refrain für die
Fußballbegeisterung der Deutschen.
Gemeinsam mit der Nationalmannschaft
treten die „Sporties“
nach dem verpassten Finale
am Brandenburger Tor in Berlin auf.
Mit dem Herz in der Hand
und der Leidenschaft im Bein
werden wir Weltmeister sein
Ich glaub’, ich werd’ das nie vergessen,
wie Meuten von Menschen völlig ausrasten,
nur weil wir „1 und 2 und
3 und 4 und“ sagen.
Doch die drei Bayern wollen sich nicht
auf das Thema Fußball beschränken.
2009 kommen leisere Töne: Mit einem
Album für die Reihe „MTV unplugged“.
… bin ich ohne dich.
Applaus, Applaus ....
Zwei Nummer-eins-Alben, mehr
als eine Million verkaufte Platten:
Auch nach 20 Jahren bleiben sich
die Sportfreunde Stiller treu.
In der Rückschau aufs eigene
Leben soll man durchaus auch
zu dem Entschluss kommen,
doch die geballte und erhobene Faust
bis zum Ende oben zu halten
und das Leben genießen
und das Leben als Fest zu sehen.
Positiv in die Vergangenheit und in die
Zukunft blicken
– typisch Sportfreunde Stiller.
Und weil du mir so viel bedeutest
bist du ein Geschenk
Du bist ein Geschenk.